Let's talk about ASCII Chan and how we might
improve it. I know you are thinking ASCII Chan
is probably perfect already. But, that's not true. We
can make it better. When an user makes a request
to ASCII Chan, we have to do a number
of things. First thing we have to do is, we
have to process the request. This basically means parsing
the HTTP. And parsing the URL. You know, doing that,
the URL mapping to the, to the right handler. You know, just
kind of all of that overhead before our program actually starts to run.
You know, figuring out what we're, what we're going to do with this
request. That takes some amount of time, you know. It, it doesn't feel
like a lot of time because it's actually not right now. But,
if you're processing millions and millions
of requests, yeah, all that little, all
that time would add up. The next thing we do, which is much
more substantial, is we clear the database. You know, we have ASCII Chan
on our program and then we have our, our database that is full of,
ASCII art of little animals and stuff. You know, our program makes a
request to the database which runs and gives us our response. Depending
on the complexity of this query, this can take
a lot of time. Not to mention, it may not
be free. If, if we're doing so many queries that
operation starts charging us that can be a big factor.
The next thing we do in a request, is we collate
the results. You know, we may have to do some sorting, we
may have to prune some of the results out because they're
spam. You know there's all sorts of things we have to do
to manipulate the results. We have to convert them into these
Python mode, Python objects from the, from our database results. All that
little maintenance stuff to get ready to actually render our HTML and
then finally we render our HTML. Now if there's lots of HTML,
this can actually take a lot of time. You know, on, on
Reddit, the actual time rendering all of that content, all that HTML. Was
non-trivial and that required some optimization. Now in ASCII Chan things are
pretty simple, but you know, like I said every website's is a little
bit different. So, what I would like you to do now just
a quick quiz to interrupt things, is which of these four tasks given
you know, you understand the nature of ASCII Chan, you've. You know your
blog has almost the exact same structure as the ASCII Chan you know,
use to submit things some ways to display a list of these things. Which of these
items do you think is the best place
to start when we're looking to improve our website?